die perfekte mann greift nicht am baum
und lagert viele wochen auf einem schiff
wie die industrie mit moderner
technologie süße mangos um die
supermärkte liefert zeigt euch sebastian
lege ich war heute in köln man muss
einkaufen rewe bio rewe edeka lidl aldi
was meinen sie welche von diesem mangos
ist die süßeste sebastian macht den test
und zwar nach wissenschaftlichen
kriterien mit hilfe eines kleinen geräts
misst er den sogenannten brics wert der
gibt an wie viel zucker im fruchtsaft
steckt je höher der brics wert desto
reifer die mango
wow 13,9 die mango ist schon mal reif
die rewe bio
der zuckergehalt hängt natürlich auch
von der sorte ab
ab 12 briggs aber schmeckt einfach jede
mango
ist richtig süß und lecker schon ein
paar messungen später zeigen sich
drastische unterschiede
die mango von edeka hat nur einen blick
wert von 10,3
das ist zwar reif heißt aber weniger
zucker die technik hat recht
geschmacklich heute die mich nicht um
die stichprobe zeigt die süße der mangos
unterscheidet sich deutlich von markt zu
markt in lebus reifeprüfung gewinnen am
ende die mangos von lidl
sie haben einen briggs wert von über 19
und damit den höchsten zuckergehalt
aber wie kommen die unterschiede
zustande
mangos werden hierzulande immer
beliebter rund 50.000 tonnen kaufen wir
jährlich die meisten aus lateinamerika
hier werden die früchte geerntet aber
nicht reif sondern grün nur so lassen
sie sich transportieren ohne dabei zu
verderben
denn die schiffsreise nach deutschland
dauert bis zu drei wochen wenn die
früchte dann hier ankommen sind sie
immer noch hart und sauer die industrie
löst das problem mit technik und chemie
mit hilfe solcher anlagen kann sie die
süße der früchte programmieren reife
meister thorsten renault erklärt wie es
geht eigentlich immer früher waren sie
halt ziemlich teuer weil man die ware
halt hierher geflogen hat aus der ganzen
sache wollten wir halt raus dafür haben
wir die reise kann man gebaut fast
32.000 mangos passen in eine kammer ein
spezialglas sorgt dafür dass die grünen
mangos gleichzeitig reif werden auf den
punkt genau
[Musik]
dazu versiegelt thorsten renault das tor
der reife kammer und zieht die luft aus
dem raum über düsen in der wand strömt
das reifegas gemisch in die kammer 96
prozent stickstoff und 4 prozent will
ihn für menschen lebensgefährlich für
mangos dagegen optimal zum siehst werden
im durchschnitt verbringen die früchte
vier bis acht tage in der kammer in der
natur brauchen sie bis zur reife rund
zehn tage und sind abhängig vom wetter
schiffstransport und reife kammer sparen
somit zeit und geld das nützt auch der
umwelt denn beim transport wird co2
eingespart
zum vergleich werden die mangos in
deutschland gereift reisen sie langsam
per schiff mit einer co2 bilanz von 0,8
kilogramm je kilo früchte reifen die
mangos dagegen vor ort müssen sie
eingeflogen werden das setzt ganze 14,6
kilo co2 frei bevor die früchte aus der
kammer in den handel kommen wird ihre
reife geprüft dazu messen wie techniker
den brics wert der früchte mit dem
gleichen gerät wie auch sebastian läge
in seiner werkstatt
[Musik]
der briggs ist so weit fortgeschritten
dass wir damit arbeiten können mit der
ware reifeprüfung bestanden
der großteil der stärke im inneren der
früchte hat sich in zucker umgewandelt
die mangos sind reif sichtbarer nachteil
der reife kammer selbst bei süßen
früchten bleibt die schale grün weil sie
keine sonne abbekommen hat genauso
geschmacklich sehr gut sein wie eine
rote oder auch nicht gelbe der innerhalb
der war drin ist ist das
ausschlaggebende
aber wie soll man dann erkennen ob eine
mango wirklich reif ist ohne sie
aufzuschneiden
die industrie setzt dabei auf hightech
maschinen blitzschnell erfassen sie für
jede einzelne mango verschiedene
qualitätsmerkmale
per laser werden unreife früchte erkannt
ein resonanz messer prüft die festigkeit
und am ende kontrolliert eine fotobox
die schale auf flecken und risse
ist die mango noch nicht reif wird sie
aussortiert und muss noch einmal zurück
in die reife kammer
der rest wird abgepackt und in diesem
fall für den verkauf im deutschen bio
handel fertig gemacht
bleibt nur die frage wenn sich die
früchte so perfekt reifen lassen warum
stoßen wir verbraucher im handel dann
auf unterschiedlich reife mangos das hat
auch etwas mit unserem einkaufsverhalten
zu tun
[Musik]
in märkten in denen die mangos schnell
über die ladentheke gehen werden kunden
eher vollreife früchte angeboten greift
die kundschaft zögerlich zu ordern die
märkte lieber weniger reife mangos denn
die verderben nicht sondern reifen noch
nach jetzt ein kleiner tipp von mir
bevor sie die nächste mango kaufen
an den kleinen spielende mal nach vorn
und hinten bewegen wenn er sich leicht
bewegen lässt wissen wir schon mal die
mango ist reif
guten appetit übrigens nicht nur mangos
werden in reife kann man behandelt
eingeführt wurde das ethylen verfahren
ursprünglich für bananen
heute werden auch avocados und papayas
zum großteil in reife kann man behandelt
so landen exotische früchte das ganze
jahr über reif bei uns in den
supermärkten und discountern ein
cleverer trick
wo kauft ihr die leckersten meint ist
von der kräfte sogar zur flug wagen sagt
es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über eure
lebensmittel wissen wollt schaut in die
nächsten zwei clips und abonniert die
zdf besser esser